what do you believe is one of the most
powerful plot construction tools
currently in the film industry
the one that i teach is
called it's a three-step process called
sequence proposition plot
that was invented by william thompson
price but was
sat undiscovered in his book until i
found it
i've taught that to development
executives at all that
hollywood studios and they consistently
say it's the most advanced development
tool in the film industry
it's really powerful and it's unlike
anything that's out there
and it's a very sophisticated
tool for both plot construction and
story development
it um works with reverse cause and
effect
and uh
structuring compelling conflict
so that it's as i was saying before
with making the overall
story work first and then making each
act work in each sequence in each scene
it's you it's used for that because
the first the first step sequence is
reverse cause and effect it's the
sequence of cause and effect
that constitute the spine of the story
the forward progression of the story so
that
using reverse cause and effect you have
to have the
mechanics of the story sketched out
first you can't
do plot construction until you have a
story reasonably well figured out
um so that
with reverse cause and effect you start
at the ending
and work backwards so that you're you're
looking at the ending and you're
chaining back
from each effect to its cause so you
look at the ending and say okay well
what would be the immediate cause of
that ending
and you find the cause of that and then
you say okay what would be the immediate
cause of that
and the cause of that and so on and
so that
say it's a
it's a um
say it's a story about a uh someone
who's being muscled by a
mafia don no someone who's being muscled
by a
corrupt cop and
the corrupt cop puts him in a good
strong dilemma
and there's no way out and it gets worse
and worse and worse
and this character finally
figures a way out and that he makes a
deal
with a mafia don to set up this corrupt
cop because the mafia don wants to take
out this corrupt cop
so the character sets a trap so that
the crooked cop shows up to like rob him
at the
at the key point and the mafiadon swoops
in and takes him out
so the ending would be that the guy
is free from the trap he was caught in
before
you'd say well what would cause him to
be free it's that the mafia don
snatches the crooked cop and disappears
him
the cause of that would be that
the crooked cop swoops in to steal the
loot
the cause of that is that he sets up
the heist the fake heist to lure the
crooked cop in
the cause of that is that he makes the
deal with the mafia dawn
so when you play that and that's all
right
dense part of the ending but you could
see the cause and effect there where
he makes the deal with the corrupt mafia
don which causes him to be able to
set up the crooked heist which causes
him to have the the loot which causes
the crooked cop to swoop in and take it
which causes the mafiodon to be able to
grab
the cop and disappear which causes them
to
walk out of the trap that he was in so
it's it's a way of
of not only stitching together
the story components by cause and effect
but actually
creating that cause and effect where it
may not exist
in other words if you have your story
roughed out and you start doing reverse
cause and effect
and you start chaining backwards through
from each effect
back to its cause you may get to a point
where
there isn't a cause in what you've
figured out so far
and that may be a hole in your plot in
the logic of the plot and you say well
what would cause that to happen
and you may come up with a bunch of
different possibilities find the one
that works and
so then you have the next cause and then
what's the cause of that
so not only are you
knitting it together as you build
backwards you're taking what you've
already got
a story that's that you've sketched out
but you're now
it's like it's like the um
when when you've designed a project and
you know exactly what you want it to do
then you bring in the engineer and say
okay make
all the nuts and bolts of this actually
work here's exactly what we want but you
got to do the engineering
so we know how heavy the steel has to be
how much concrete to pour
and they'll give you hard numbers of
like you need
this much concrete and this much steel
so there's one thing of what you want to
achieve but there's another of
the engineer comes in and makes it all
tells you what to do to make it all work
it's that kind of thing that as you
take the story you've roughed out and
stitch it together
engineer it that you actually
create the cause and effect as you build
and the trick to that tool is that you
are
asking at each point only what is the
cause
of that effect rather than what happens
before it
because any number of things can happen
before it but only one thing actually
caused it so that's a way to help
separate the necessary from the
unnecessary
it what it does is it frees you from the
profusion of unnecessary detail
the unnecessary kills scripts and that's
one of the things i was saying
i've trained a lot of um creative
executives
in at the you know the studios in
hollywood
in this tool and when i talk about
separating the necessary from the
unnecessary they're all going
yes you know the unnecessary overburdens
everything dialogues overwritten scenes
that shouldn't be there
whole acts which they're bombarded by
the unnecessarily constantly
it's one of the major symptoms they see
of that scripts don't work that dialogue
doesn't work
the spine of the story doesn't work
because there's too much there's
you don't have the what's necessary and
there's too much of the unnecessary it's
a
combination of the two so
what merely happens before an event
could be any number of things
the thing that actually causes it is
going to be among those things that
happens before it
but you're finding the the key
links you're basically you're you're
creating a chain
as you work backwards and when you
create the chain for the overall story
the chain of events
and you've rigorously included only that
which is necessary to the forward action
of the story
and you've rigorously excluded that
which is
unnecessary to the forward progression
of events that constitute the spine of
your story
then you've assembled it backwards out
of your
what the material you have and when you
find holes in your plot you invent to
fill them in so you're not only
structuring it but you're also
developing it you're creating when
needed
um then when you read it
from the bottom up a causes b which
causes c which causes d
and so on that's the spine of your story
whereas before you had a lot of
clever elements to a story and it looked
like it worked but you hadn't
done the engineering on it to make sure
it really
worked and
being able to stand back and look at
your story
like it starts here and it moves all
through here
it also enables you to get a good
objective look
at what you've created so far and
it's not easy to get a good objective
look at something you've been deeply
immersed in for a while
because this plot construction comes
after you've done a lot of creation and
development then you have to stitch it
all together into something that
actually holds water
so when you stand back and look at it
you may go oh there's the whole
spine of the story in simple terms and
you may go
wow that's much better than i thought it
was going to be or you may go
god that really sucks i thought i had
much more than this but
there it is and i gotta
like and you know it's it's it's it can
it can be
not working for you in any number of
areas
or you may go you know i always thought
there was a
some kind of problem in act two but i
couldn't put my finger on it but boom
there i see it right there
and you can see that part of it is
distinctly weak and it could be
so much stronger and so you know maybe
you fix it in an afternoon or maybe it's
three weeks or maybe it takes a month
maybe you have to read a couple great
books or talk to somebody who really
lived it
and then you come back and stitch it all
back together again
and then look at it again and go much
better but this one piece is
still weak so you're evaluating
developing
structuring and it's all in the process
of plot construction
so once you've done
the the sequence that's the sequence of
events that
the overall story consists of just the
big picture
then so that's sequence out of sequence
proposition plot
three-step process so the second step
comes from price's proposition that we
were talking about before
using logic to pull all the story
elements
together into a coherent hole like we
were talking about how
pulp fiction has three different stories
in it
but tarantino did an excellent job of
pulling those all together into a
coherent whole
it's not a mess of different stuff it's
one thing
that happens to be done in an unusual
way but it's still
perfectly crafted from a dramatic point
of view it's it's extremely effective
dramatically
and great storytelling has got both so
once you've got this tight chain of
events then
you set up a set up a conflict set up a
potential conflict early on in the story
touch off a fight to the finish later in
the story
and what price said is instead of doing
a and b therefore c
he said central to our job as a
dramatist
is to have the audience up on the edge
of their seat at the point
when the fight to the finish has only
just started
and they don't know how it's going to
turn out so at the point when
the fight to the finish has only just
started
the audience comes up on the edge of
their seat like how's this going to turn
out
because we've got a powerful proactive
protagonist
and we've got a powerful proactive
antagonist and we genuinely don't
genuinely don't know who's going to win
how it's going to turn out
and so you set it up you touch it off
you get the audience on the edge of
their seat and you've either got the
audience or you don't
in terms of dramatic power on a scale of
1 to 10
how much are they on the edge of their
seat
if it's really powerful then you're
going wow yes this
i set it up i touched it off and i
really got the audience
if you set it up and you touch it off
and you can see it's still
kind of weak or it's actually quite weak
that's the power that's what the
proposition is for so you can propose it
take an objective look at it and then
evaluate it and then revise as needed
if it's only like a seven out of ten and
you're like no it needs to be i need a
nine or a ten
in terms of a scale of one to ten for
how powerfully
i have the audience on the edge of their
seat at this point when the
when what the whole story is built up to
is unresolved
then you amplify different aspects of it
to get the audience that much more on
the edge of their seat
so you're you're creating a tight
sequence of cause and effect
then looking at the core conflict in the
story because it's really just
two boxers in a ring fighting it out
it's two dogs fighting over a bone
only one of them is going to walk away
in the end in fact the oldest greek
drama was only two characters on stage
the introduction of the third character
by sophocles was considered a major
innovation in drama
so the ability to see the core of your
plot as
two main
fighters in a fight to the finish and
only one of them is going to walk away
helps you get right at the core of what
makes your story work dramatically
so um sequence is
the reverse sequence of cause and effect
that makes it tight
this you set it up you touch it off you
get the audience on the edge of their
seat
unresolved and if you're doing your job
right
the question in their mind about how
it's going to turn out is
really powerful then you've got
as much dramatic power as you can bring
to the to how you're dramatizing this
story
and then the last step is the
answering of the riddle the completion
of the action what how the fight to the
finish
shakes out in the back and forth between
protag and his antagonist and who wins
or loses in the end
so reverse cause and effect set up the
fight touch it off get the audience on
the edge of their seat
and wrap it up so that's sequence
proposition plot
and you do that once to the overall
story which makes it tight and dramatic
and well i'll explain that as i go along
then
as i said you break the overall story up
into acts like you literally
look at the chain of cause and effect
that you did in reverse
and you say okay that right there is the
end of act one
that right there is the end of act two
so you've got your axe
so you take act one and now you do
sequence proposition plot to act
one so you start at the ending of act
one where it ends up
and you've already got like if you had
this chain of events
this part of it is act one so you've got
a chain of events right there that
constitute act one
you take that over here and you you so
you look at that
chain of events and you're going to
start at the end again
and work backwards through it and think
it through in a little more detail
so that you take what you've got
and you say okay so the like
the cop comes in and grabs the loot
and the mafia guy grabs him and
disappears him
so now you're going to think that
through in a little more it now becomes
necessary
to figure it out in a little more detail
you didn't want much detail when you're
doing the overall story because you want
to just see
the main building blocks with nothing
else in there
because that's got to work and if you
get
swamped by a profusion of unnecessary
detail it can be hard to see the forest
for the trees
it can be hard to stand back and go wow
that chain of events is the whole story
you don't want extra you want it
stripped down so you can evaluate it
now it becomes necessary to think it
through in a little more detail it
becomes necessary
to layer in a little more detail so
you're thinking it through in a little
more detail of like okay so
is it like a bag of money or is it like
diamonds or is it somebody that he was
supposed to kidnap for the crooked cop
and how would what would the rough
mechanics of the trap
consist of like where would the mafia
guy be and
how do they make it so the cop really
puts his foot in the trap
even if there might be clues that he
might begin to suspect or he has good
instinct and he's like
something's wrong but he still puts his
foot in the trap
so you you
it becomes necessarily necessary to
figure out a little more detail
and then you chain backwards to that to
the to the you
you're looking at what you already
created like what was the cause of that
is that
he does the actual heist
that the crooked cop wants them to do
but there's some falsehoods in it
because it's a setup
how does that go down how does he do it
is the crooked cop watching
what is he taking is he swapping it for
something that's
a key part of the trap so you're you
don't you don't want
much detail because you you wanna it's
hard enough to figure it out and too
much detail
can just come up the works um
and then you go back to the next
you you look at what the next cause was
and think that through so what you've
done
is you may have like six causes that you
started out with that you brought from
the overall story
and you've opened it up a bit more so
maybe now there's 12 or something like
that
so you expand upon what you already had
amplifying in detail
and you've got more then you throw that
act into a two-sided conflict where you
set up a potential fight
early on in the act touch off a fight to
the finish later in the act
get the audience up on the edge of their
seat about how the conflict in that act
is going to turn out
and then a completion of that action of
what's what's the rest of it
so you've done sequence proposition plot
so you've not only constructed
the story but you're literally inventing
your
story development as well you're
figuring out okay so what would actually
be in that bag that helps make the trap
work
but the cop doesn't see the switcheroo
or whatever
you're gradually developing those
details without getting into too much
detail
but you're you're literally fleshing it
out you're literally inventing
some of it you'll have the details
already figured out some of it you're
making up on the spot and then you're
creating conflict in that act which
there generally will be some conflict
but you're really constructing it
setting up a potential fight touching
off a fight to the finish in that act
getting the audience out on the edge of
the receipt so the act itself
has a high point of suspense at around
the two thirds three chorus point
that really gets the audience up on the
edge of their seat and then complete the
action so you've made it tight and
dramatic
then you do the same thing for act two
you expand upon the cause and effect
thinking
each step through in a little more
detail you
amplify whatever conflict is in that act
making sure you have a strong proactive
antagonist and protagonist
touch off a fight to the finish get the
audience on the edge of their seat
so act two really gets the audience on
the edge of our seat it's compelling
and and it's it you have a completion of
the action within that act
so now act two is tight and dramatic
then you do the same thing for act
three then you go back to act one and
break that
into sequences there are two to five
sequences
in that act and you take if this is the
cause and effect
for act one then you say okay so if this
is the bottom
the beginning and this is the end so you
say okay so that much of it's going to
be
the opening sequence that much is the
next sequence that much is the next
sequence you take this chunk
bring it over here and think it through
in a little more detail
you expand upon it and open it up and
you're figuring out the mechanics of the
cause and effect for that sequence
and you're still rigorously excluding
the unnecessary and using
only that which is necessary to the
forward progression
of the action in that sequence and then
you structure the conflict
you set up a fight touch off a fight get
the audience on the edge of their seat
and resolve it within that sequence
so that sequence you've now flushed it
out thought it through
made it tight kept the unnecessary out
of it
and structured compelling conflicts so
that it gets the audience up on the edge
of their seat
two-thirds three-quarters of the way
through the sequence and then complete
the action
so you do that for each sequence in the
story maybe there's 12 to 15 sequences
in the story maybe some more
but that's a lot of work but so is 24
rewrites
so you're engineering your script
properly before you write it
so you do it for all the sequences
throughout the whole story
then you go back to the opening sequence
and you look at the cause and effect
you've got for that
and you break that into scenes you can
say okay this chunk of it is
the opening scene that's the next scene
and so on
so then you take that chunk of the
opening scene that's the cause and
effect that you've already figured out
and then you at the scene level you
think it through again you go backwards
through it visualizing it in more detail
what would be
now you're down to final detail what
would be the mechanics of who
actually does exactly what and you're
paraphrasing the dialogue
so now you've got cause and effect for
that scene and then you structure the
conflict in that scene
because you never want any part of your
story to go flat dramatically you don't
want scenes that are mere
information they're mere narrative you
want the scene itself
to be tight and dramatic so two-thirds
three-quarters of the way through the
scene the audience comes up on the edge
of the seat
so you made it tight and dramatic and
then you write that scene
then you do the same thing for the next
scene you you do the reverse cause and
effect
thinking it through in more detail
dramatizing it and then you write that
scene
you go all the way through writing each
scene as you
develop and structure it and then you
have a working draft
and so that's the
function of sequence proposition plot as
a
plot construction tool it also happens
to be
very much a story development tool the
two go
hand in hand and glove but it's a
remarkably powerful tool
price constructed it
but didn't
complete it he explains it very clearly
but nobody else picked up on it
and you know i read a lot of his
students books and so on and they picked
up on proposition
and that really entered the the lexicon
of structural technique for the
dramatist
not widely but it's it's certainly known
um but none of his students were talking
about sequence proposition
plot his student who you know the two
books that i read for three years
that student student didn't even talk
about reverse cause and effect which
price went on and on and on about
so i was like how could they not be
seeing this but it was like
you know finding an old rusty tool out
in the field
behind da vinci's old workshop that had
just laid there for hundreds of years
and nobody ever
tripped over it and i found it and was
like this works and i
combined it with what his students did
it really wasn't there
price described it but
didn't build it at all and he wasn't
even satisfied with
the proposition part of it but his
student did a lot of detective work
because he
knew that price had a remarkably
powerful tool but it died before he
wrote his next book and explained it so
he did a lot of detective work
and pieced together made the proposition
more sophisticated and powerful
and then this other playwriting teacher
made the proposition
work even better and i used all of those
and synthesized them together
so this was like an old tool that i
found
synthesized together with some of what
his students said and then i added to it
and then worked extensively with it for
many years
so it doesn't really exist anywhere
and when i started teaching people kept
saying
that they'd never seen anything like
what i teach and that it worked better
than anything out there
so
partly i didn't expose myself to other
dramatic writing teachers
because i didn't want to start pirating
what they were saying i wanted to just
stick with the with the uniqueness of
this
and it it works you know it's a complete
working technique
um but it's
it really is like nothing people have
ever seen and
it really works powerfully and it's
it's very much plot construction uh one
of the things i say that's kind of fun
is um i only teach one thing
plot construction and dramatic principle
it's kind of a coin in a certain way
because there are obviously two things
but plot construction comes out of
dramatic principle
if you understand dramatic principle the
mc that
the underlying principles that make
dramatic structure work
then dramatic principle informs plot
construction they're
very much the same thing in the same way
that
medical theory informs brain surgery or
something like that
they're they're very much different
parts of the same
animal
okay so i hope that was clear
absolutely are both books required
reading or is one of them out of print
actually neither
price's book is very dense reading
and hard slogging
his students book is really excellent
but i synthesize them to you can
definitely learn from reading them but
you can learn
more quickly from studying my book
writing a great movie because it
it synthesized
a lot of their tools into a powerful
unit
price's book is kind of like
walking through thigh deep mud it's not
it's hard slogging and it's
it's a lot of work um
[Music]
so anybody can go find it it's it's
easy to find but it's it's
brutally hard work um and you won't find
what's in my book in those books in a
lot of ways
you